you wake up in the West we begin with
breaking news on two former presidents
Barack Obama and Bill Clinton the US
Secret Service says it intercepted an
apparent explosive device sent to the
Obama home in Washington earlier this
morning that follows an apparent pipe
bomb that sources say was found near the
Clinton's home in Chappaqua north of New
York City addressed to Hillary Clinton
now all this happened just one day after
a pipe bomb was found near the New York
home of Democratic Party mega donor
George Soros Paula Reed is with us from
the White House now with more on this
story Paula what do you know good
morning an official tells CBS News they
believe that the explosive device found
sent to the Clintons is similar to the
one found at the home of George Soros
now the pipe bomb that was found at the
Clinton's tropical residence during
routine mail screenings screenings was
discovered this morning now a second
device was sent to the Washington DC
home of former President Barack Obama
but at this point officials cannot say
if that one is linked to the one found
at the Clinton's home or the home of
George Soros the Secret Service says
none of these packages was actually were
actually delivered and no none of the
targets were actually at risk currently
this is being investigated as a criminal
matter by the FBI Gail thank you very
much Paul of course that investigation
continues but John all former presidents
have Secret Service protection do they
not right no they do they have them for
for life and their families do as well
the Secret Service doesn't you tell
everybody about everybody and the
families that are covered but the reason
of course that they do is we have the
tragic history in America of presidents
being attacked or assassinated and
because we have presidents living longer
than they used to there is a larger
longer period where you have ex
presidents out in the world and
particularly given the partisans nature
of things people attach their animus
towards a political party towards the
biggest figures in those parties and
those are usually always the
ex-president it sounds like a good idea
that they all their mail a screen before
it reaches the house so it never came in
contact with the family of course we
will continue to follow that story and
bring you the latest as soon as we get
it